the soundtrack is loud and the guns are
loaded these men are preparing for
battle in eastern Ukraine and they've
traveled a long way to get here
they're foreign Fighters with a single
aim joke like energy to defeat the
Russians in combat killing is not easy
for a human we are human
Russians not a normal human
they're volunteers from Georgia who
serve in a unit called The Georgian
Legion
it has more than a thousand men at the
front including Misha who says he's come
to settle a score the Russians cause
problems at home
[Music]
formed in 2014 the Georgian Legion is
one of several International brigades
now fighting for Ukraine
and their members taking a Russian
position here last month are drawn from
a variety of countries some 50 britons
currently serve we met the battalion's
commander
when we choose the soldier not to have
radical views not to come here to kill
somebody we need them to protect
somebody not to kill somebody some of
the people who come are adventurous we
don't accept it in Adventures we don't
accept you know Nazis racists or do you
reject of course so we rejected a lot of
people a lot I mean I would say we
rejected more than
70 percent of who applied to Georgian
Legion back on the mission Misha and his
team prepare to strike assembling a
mortar behind an abandoned house a
hit-and-run deployment they worked at
speed trying to avoid detection by the
Russians everyone was worried about the
enemy
when the Drone pilot found the target
the unit began to fire
I'll go
ten shells in 20 minutes
detonation monitored by the Drone the
Georgians say they struck a command post
around 75 percent destroyed but they
knew their attack would reveal our
location and we waited for the sound of
Russian fire sickening feeling
nine shells
and now we're waiting for the Russian
response
we heard the thought of Russian shells
Landing in a nearby field but Misha said
it wasn't time to panic
foreign
[Music]
a few minutes later the decision was
made it was time to leave our position
and we left as swiftly as we had arrived
gotta get out of here quickly
I asked the unit leader if the danger
had passed when will you start to relax
so that would be something
his Commander mamuka says he won't Relax
The Georgian seeks the destruction of
Vladimir Putin's regime I was trying to
learn the alternative way but he doesn't
work with Russia so he becomes senseless
so that there was not agreement that
Russia has not broken so
naturally we have to fight the only
language that I should understand is the
sound of a bullet
[Music]
Mission completed there was time to
unwind the relief mingling with the rap
music
it's a dangerous business going to war
with Russia but there are foreign
citizens who demand their say
John Sparks Sky News near zapparesia